[Music]
[Music]
all right sup guys I'm could be--if see
here and this is it this is our first
look and actual hands-on with the new
Samsung Galaxy fold so ever since it was
unveiled a couple weeks ago I've been
just sort of fascinated by this phone
like Samsung never let anyone touch it
they never showed it to anyone they only
had a very specific demo footage for a
while it kind of fell like a myth but
now suddenly I'm actually holding one so
the basic concept in case you forgot
Galaxy fold has one smaller outer screen
and one large folding inner screen in a
single device for 1980 bucks this is my
very first impressions of the final
phone that people paying this money will
actually get so right off the bat this
phone is chunky so we kind of saw it
coming with other folding phones like
the Royale flex Pi and even the huawei
mate X but it kind of has basically the
feel of two small Samsung phones put
back-to-back next to each other with a
hinge in between and it doesn't go all
the way completely flat against each
other when it's closed like a sandwich
instead they create this little angle
like a small triangle and in the phone's
shape like this folded up is just really
tall and narrow so it's got this like
candy bar sort of feel and it's pretty
heavy as well
now the screen on the front as you might
remember is a four point six inch cover
display very tall and then when you flip
it open you get a seven point three inch
OLED display that's nearly exactly four
by three so pretty wide now I know a
main question a lot of people have about
this is probably about the crease down
in the middle where it folds so to be
perfectly clear yes you can see the
crease especially when you're just a
little bit off axis or if you have a
light wallpaper and yes you can't even
feel it when you run your finger over it
so it's not this perfectly precisely
flat uninterrupted glass feel but
honestly it gets pretty close like when
you're looking at it straight on you can
easily forget about it and it's again
much better than that real flex pay I
saw see yes although I guess that wasn't
a very high bar to clear and also I
gotta say the actual closing and
unfolding movement of opening and
closing it is extremely satisfying I
wish I brought my mic to
hands-on so you could actually hear the
thunk sound that it makes when it closes
but there's some strong magnets in
either half of the phone that open and
close and connect it it's so strong you
could actually like pick up paper clips
with the phone but that opening and
closing that funk it makes I kind of
love that and a hinge it just sort of
snaps open to a full hundred eighty
degree flat position and everywhere in
between those two positions is pretty
fluid to whatever angle you want but it
definitely feels like it's Springs are
trying to pull itself closed but yeah
opening and closing the phone is
definitely a two-handed operation I
tried it with one hand and of course I
really really didn't want to drop it and
I couldn't do it so it's definitely
gonna be a two-handed process
I'm sure that's what we mostly expected
and actually that process can get kind
of tricky sometimes with the interesting
button layout so there's a power button
on the side of the phone where you'd
probably expect it there's also the
volume rocker and also a separate
fingerprint reader for unlocking that
doubles as a Bigsby button so it's
actually incredibly easy to accidentally
trigger bixby whether you're unlocking
the phone or just trying to fold it or
unfold it I guess that's the classic
Samsung okay a few other things I did
notice one Samsung did technically just
make a phone with a notch and no
headphone jack kind of sad I guess but
it actually does come with their new
Galaxy buds they're wireless headphones
so that's cool and the notch on the
inside screen which holds two cameras
and a bunch of other sensors actually
has this lip to it that's sort of raised
up from the rest of the screen but the
Notification pulldown actually doesn't
work from that side when you're unfolded
anyway so I guess it's not a big deal
that the lip is there but you definitely
still get it cutting into things like
videos and games or really anything
that's fullscreen and then speaking of
cameras this phone actually has six
total camera sensors so there's the 10
megapixel selfie camera on the front
when it's closed then you open it up and
you get that notch which has an
identical 10 megapixel selfie camera
with an additional depth sensor like the
galaxy s 10 plus and then on the back
yes in a camera bump on this already
pretty thick phone you have the standard
the ultra wide and the telephoto cameras
just like the galaxy s 10 had so you'll
never be at a shortage of cameras and
lenses here and you can see just looking
at the phone Samsung had to do a lot of
creative things just
to get the fold to work like a normal
phone there's some special adhesive in
the display and of course the folding
plastic that actually folds on the front
they also split the battery into two
parts one in each half of the phone and
it's all connected through this very
special hinge design but they still did
manage to get high-end specs in there
you got your snapdragon 855 12 gigs of
ram your 512 gigs of storage not
expandable and then you have your stereo
speakers you still have reverse wireless
charging and the combined battery is
huge it's four thousand three hundred
eighty milliamp hours so it's really
equipped to actually work and get work
done now there are two main features to
take advantage of the fact that it folds
continuity and multi-window
so the continuity is interesting but it
does make sense so you do have totally
separate wallpaper and home screen
layouts on both the front and the back
screens they're independent of each
other but with supported apps which are
mostly Samsung and Google apps right now
you can open them on the small screen
then unfold the phone and they will
continue where you left off on the big
screen and it actually works pretty
quickly and surprisingly well much
faster than that one time on stage that
we first saw the demo so I open the Play
Store scroll down a little bit then
unfolded the phone and the Play Store
was open and even scrolled down a bit
where I left off that is dope another
good application for it was Google Maps
which we've seen the demos of on stage
but I tried it I opened up Google Maps
and I clicked on this business listing
and then when I unfolded the phone that
listing was open where I left off just
much bigger so I got to play with this
more I think it also works with YouTube
videos and some other apps I'm gonna
test that a lot that should be really
interesting but that other feature I
mentioned is multi window and I guess as
you'd expect with a huge screen on the
inside and twelve gigs of RAM and
everything you can easily have multiple
apps open at once you just have to swipe
in from the right side and all the
supporting apps will show up and you can
have two apps side by side and you can
adjust the size of the window the border
between them and everything and that's
that's about as far as I would typically
go but you can keep opening and keep
bringing in apps and adding floating
windows and even more up to a total of 8
apps open at
and you can have most of them in these
sort of floating multi windows now I
don't know kind of persons doing that
much multitasking on a little seven inch
screen that person probably needs a full
size tablet anyway but it's cool that
they'll let you go crazy and won't limit
you up till eight apps so overall I'm
coming away from that initial hands-on
pretty impressed like it's always scary
when a company announces something but
then doesn't let you touch it and they
don't want you to like ever use it until
it's about to come out so I was a bit
nervous about actually being a complete
finished feeling product but it does
feel pretty good now if I nitpick even a
little bit of course I'm gonna find all
sorts of stuff that's not ideal you know
the outside screen being the main one
it's so small and has so much bezel and
hearing four point six inches doesn't
sound that small but I found it actually
even difficult to type on with the
keyboard open on the small screen and
then there's the knotch stuff being a
little bit weird and the slightly
incomplete not quite fold is kind of
weird
the price is super high you know there's
all that stuff but you know what at the
end of day even if you never use the
screen on the front you still get a big
screen that folds in half and fits in
your pocket that's the part that feels
like the future and the big screen is of
course a better camera viewfinder a
better web browser a better video
washing experience and all of that is
super cool it's a step in the right
direction and this is definitely gonna
be one of those phones people actually
want to get in the stores and play with
and open close and see for themselves if
they're into it but there will also be
much more video coverage coming
including a full review on this channel
so if you want to be subscribed so you'd
be the first to see that definitely do
that below also this is the last day to
get in on this merch drop so if you want
any of the new stuff it'll be I think
open till the end of today so within a
couple hours of this video dropping make
sure you get in on the merch as well but
that's pretty much it that's my first
impressions of the galaxy fold
definitely let me know in the comments
what other stuff you want to know about
it because if you haven't already
noticed that box right there that's the
galaxy fold I'm gonna be getting into it
for the full review and of course more
coverage to come so let me know what you
guys want to see but until then what do
you think would you get a galaxy fold
for your full time phone thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace